Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
I'd to share a narration with you
this evening that helps us with
something that is
something that we are in dire need of.
When you look at the world, you look at
the problems that people have. You look
at the confusion that people have. It's
not because people don't know what's
right and what's wrong. It's not because
people have ignorance as to what's good
or bad.
In a macro sense, people know what's
good and bad. In a general broad sense,
people know good from evil.
However,
in a more specific sense, the Muslims
because they are not going only based on
societal norms and their fra but as well
from the teachings of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, the Quran and the
Sunnah,
they have an even more detailed
understanding of right and wrong.
And most people want in a general sense,
most Muslims want what's right and want
to avoid what's wrong. But the question
is why is there so much chaos? Chaos in
between people, chaos in society, chaos
in single households, chaos even in a
person's own self and in his own life.
Why does a person contradict himself so
much? Why is there so much confusion?
And why is there this overwhelming sense
of confusion that we suffer from? It's
not because we don't know right and
wrong. It's not because we don't know
the general broad strokes of Islam law,
Islamic law. It's because our priorities
are not aligned properly.
See, knowledge isn't really just about
knowing right from wrong. Most people
know that. True knowledge is knowing not
only what's right, but what's better and
what's good. And knowing the difference
between what's bad and what's worse.
Knowing the difference between
priorities. Knowing the difference that
if two potential goods,
if they present themselves, which one is
more worthy of a person's attention? If
two evils present themselves, which evil
is the lesser of the two evils? That is
what knowledge is.
and our priorities
and the way that we have them
structured, the very murky way that many
people or even most people's priorities
are structured is the reason why human
beings suffer so much. It's because of
our priorities. They're out of whack. We
don't have a list in our mind where this
is top priority. This is second from the
top. This is third from the top. And if
you have that, 99% of all of your
decisions are already made before you
even step onto the battlefield.
99%
of all of your decisions are already
made before you even go out into the
world.
Our prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
teaches us how to prioritize
and the biggest problem is a lot of us
are still at the first stage of our list
of priorities. What is the first stage
of the list of priorities?
Which is primary dunya or the hereafter?
Which takes precedence? the dunya or the
hereafter.
Which one do I embrace holy and in
detail and the other in a general sense?
Which is the one that is my primary
focus and the rest fits into that?
This is the priorities of the believer.
In a general sense, the dunya is
secondary. The hereafter is primary.
What does that mean? That means that
when we look at the world,
we see it through the eyes or through
the lens of the hereafter.
When we look at this dunya and this
world, what is permissible, what is
impermissible, what is good, what is
bad, we don't see it through the lens of
this world. We see it from our
perspective as standing in front of
Allah on the day of judgment. And we
look back at the world, what you would
see in that instance, that is how the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam taught his
companions to see the dunya.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us about the dunya and the hereafter.
He says in the narration of
collected by Ahmed or Abdah Ahmed in his
extension or addition to his father's
Muslim
[Silence]
for
as an introduction.
The scholars of Islam
have ref have
referred to the dunya and the hereafter.
These two existences, the existence of
the duny, the existence of the
hereafter, they refer to them as
anyone know what is.
Huh?
Is co-wives. Yes. Second wife, co-wives.
They refer to the dunya and the
hereafter as co-wives. This is a very
good explanation description.
Why are they co-wives? Because it's
impossible to satisfy both
simultaneously. It's never going to
happen.
It's never going to happen.
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala tells us
about co-wives and our wives
that we can never fully be absolutely
equal.
100% with them.
Meaning that in our physical being,
Allah tells us you will never be able to
be absolutely equal
with both of your wives or with each of
your wives.
Meaning that you can give each of them a
gift at the same time. You can give each
of them the same exact treatment, the
same exact time. But what is not in your
control, how you feel, how you feel is
not in your control.
And as we just heard in our prayer, the
human being's heart is often very
constricted.
We can only experience things in small
doses. And we only have our attention.
Most people only have attention for one
thing at a time. And so it's not
possible to make both of them satisfied.
So the scholars from this verse refer to
the dunya and the hereafter as co-wives
because you will only be able to fully
satisfy one of the two, not both. You
can't be equal with both. You can't love
both with the same heart. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
we have never placed two hearts in the
chest of one man ever. You get one
heart. Which one does it belong to?
And so in this narration, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam expounds upon this.
He says whomever the dunya is his is
preoccupied
mainly with the dunya.
Whomever's preoccupation
is with the dunya. Whoever's focus is on
the dunya
Allah will make his affair
scattered and unorganized. His affairs
will become scattered
and he will place his poverty in front
of his eyes.
[Silence]
He says whomever is whomever's
preoccupation is with the dunya.
In other words, whomever the dunya is
primary and the hereafter is secondary.
You give the meat and potatoes as we say
in America in the south. You give the
meat and potatoes to the dunya and you
give the scraps to the hereafter. Right?
Whomever is that that is his situation.
His Allah will make his affair scattered
and unorganized. And he will place his
poverty right in front of his eyes.
Anywhere he looks, he can't see what he
has. All he can see is what he wishes he
had. All he can see is what he doesn't
have. All he can see is what he needs to
go get before time runs out.
He says, "And after all that, the only
thing he will receive of the dunya is
what Allah had already written for him."
After all that punishment and stress and
tears and sweat and blood and what did
you get at the end of all of that?
Exactly what Allah had written for you.
50,000 years before the creation of the
heavens and the earth.
He says sallall.aii wasallam.
Conversely,
whomever the hereafter is his primary,
whomever's focus and preoccupation is
with the hereafter,
Allah will organize his affairs for him.
And he will place his wealth in his
heart for him. and the dunya
will come to him in spite of itself. Now
notice how he's saying this because the
human being our state of being is
constantly what? Mali marry me. My
money, my money, my wealth, my dy. We're
always afraid we're missing out. Why do
you think people can't leave their phone
in the car when they come in the masid?
I'm not picking on anybody here, but why
do we think that is?
Marry, I'm afraid I'm going to miss
something of the dunya. Something of the
dunya is going to happen. Logic plays no
part of this. The first thing someone
will tell you is, well, what if there's
an emergency?
If there's an emergency, unless you're a
fireman or a police officer or you're a
paramedic, right? They shouldn't be
calling you. They should be calling 911.
What are you going to do from where you
are at the masid? Right? all these years
of these hypothetical emergencies that
are are intruding in our lives. How many
of us have really gotten a phone call in
the masjid during an emergency in our
entire life? Ever. A true emergency.
Most of us never. I would wager most of
us, if not all of us, never.
Th This is the trick. We we we have this
feeling in ourselves that we're afraid
to miss out.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has made
it to where the human being has one
heart. You have to give this heart. You
can only let into this heart one at a
time. You can't be with both wives at
the same time. It does not work. They're
too jealous of each other. They demand
your all. And so you have to choose one.
Which one is it? You can't let both of
them into your heart. It's either the
dunyas in your heart
or the hereafter's in your heart. They
are mutually exclusive of one another.
It's either nighttime or it's daytime.
They are two opposites.
So you have to choose one. Which one is
it? And when we say choose one, it
doesn't mean that you're going to
completely miss out on the other. No.
What it means is you will miss out on
things of the dunya. You will you'll
miss out. But that's okay
because what you're missing out on Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has for you.
Allah tells us you all give precedent.
You all give precedence to the dunya in
spite of the hereafter being better and
more extensive. It's eternal and it in
itself is better. It's not built on
deprivation.
And so the thing here is that the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam promises
you that if the hereafter is your
primary focus, you will miss out of the
dunya and you'll be preoccupied. But he
promises you the dunya will come to you
in it in spite of itself.
Don't worry, you won't starve.
If you follow the path of Muhammad Sam,
you will not starve.
Instead, you will flourish and your
heart will be wealthy, which is the
greatest wealth there could ever be. The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells us
He says true wealth is not a wealth of
possessions. True wealth is wealth of
the heart. And that's what Allah means
when he says,
"And you were poor before and he made
you wealthy." What does that mean? One
could argue the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam never saw the kind of physical
poverty after he was a prophet that he
saw before or that he saw before after.
He was never that poor. After he was a
prophet, poverty and famine took hold so
much that they had to tie stones on
their stomach from hunger. That didn't
happen in the days of Jahya.
So what does that mean? Well, what it
means is they had empty stomachs, but
they had full hearts.
As opposed to
many or most of mankind full stomachs
[Arabic recitation]